لم أقم بدعمهم جميعًا
لأكون صريحًا ، حيث سيستمتع بهذه
العطلات في مكان ما أنا متأكد من
ذلك ، لكنني سأشعر بخيبة أمل كبيرة
بالطبع لأن فريقه لم
يحضر إلى كأس العالم كما تعلم.  يرغب أفضل
اللاعبين في العالم باللعب
في كأس العالم وهو بالتأكيد
أحدهم ، لذا سيصاب بخيبة أمل
كبيرة لأنه لم يفعل ذلك أو لم يفعله وفريقه
هنا
، ومن الواضح أن ساديو يعد حدثًا ضخمًا.
خيبة أمل بالنسبة له ، لقد تحدثت إليه
بشكل واضح عندما سمعت عن
إصابته ، أعني أنه من الواضح أنه أصيب
بخيبة أمل كبيرة لأنه لم يستطع فعل ذلك ، فأنا أعرف
كيف كانت سادي كشخص وإذا
كانت هناك فرصة صغيرة كان
سيعطيها بالتأكيد  يجب أن تكون
إصابة سيئة للغاية ولكن أتمنى أن يتعافى
بشكل جيد وأتمنى أن يحصل على
فرصة أخرى في المستقبل